hey guys how's it going i'm just seeing
this my sister jenna hello you should
probably already know this by now i have
brought her in because i want to discuss
the pumpkin spice latte phenomenon at
starbucks
so it is seriously like the craziest
thing and what makes me just die
laughing is people are calling them psl
for real like they're seriously calling
them that hey can you give me a psl but
like the thing is it's like the same how
many syllables like pumpkin spice wow
pokemon or psl can you get me on psl i
need to get a psl is it funny or is it
just completely a white girl hashtag
white girl obnoxious all i see is people
posting pictures of their starbucks
drinks so many facebook updates oh my
gosh the psl is back psl psl why do we
feel the need to post our starbucks i
don't know
really don't understand i'm not going to
stop posting though i'm always like are
you taking another selfie with your
starbucks like i think we get it tell
them about the psf oh we love to annoy
our other sister like it's honestly my
favorite thing to do so we kept
messaging her if you want a psl we're
going to starbucks i'll get you a psl
and her boyfriend was with her and we're
like does he want to pee us out and she
replied no he gets the psf
about lost i said my mind hold the phone
psf
f and i wrote back question mark
yes
[Music]
oh my gosh do you want to go it's like a
hot day so we should probably do better
now to get a psi this is the perfect
thing because right before fall it's hot
you get the psf it's true a couple weeks
later called psl psl what i want to know
is who has had a psl does anybody have a
psf what is your favorite she said a
drink at said coffee shop doesn't have
to be starbucks psl psf yeah
psf i think that's really it for i think
i wanted this rant to be a little more
extensive but i'm not really sure if
it's a rant or if i'm a part of the
problem i'm a part of you're definitely
part of the problem but no they said we
were like well do you guys have pumpkin
spice frappuccinos and they're like we
can make them so i think it's like a big
secret i'm just going to end it oh you
hit me in the eye did i
use my pso pumpkin spice latte 10 years
of psl lol psf ps1 psl i've been saying
it so much that i keep saying i keep
forgetting like what is it pl unlike pll
pl
all right that's all for this video let
me know what's your favorite drink at um
what's your favorite drink is any drink
psl psl it's not a psl then get out of
town
out of focus jenna
what focus
focus but i feel so unfocused
you're not
and finally i decided to click on one of
you guys who tweeted it to me it's what
does the fox say